dès 17h45 j'étais déjà venu avec les
chats les services un certain nombre de
personnes
nous sommes venus à 15 heures puisque on
suit l'arrivée des arcs minute par
minute et ont mené à train de mettre en
place des choses dans tous les services
tous les services sont concernés
d'abord les principaux services et
ensuite les autres pour que je n'ai pas
dû qu'on soit prêt mais qu'on ait fait
le maximum propice est-ce que vous avez
identifié des populations
particulièrement à risque qui pourraient
être déplacées oui oui parce que je les
dis à l'époque d'avril nous avons des
personnes qui habitent au jaune mort né
dans le monde nous avons aussi des
personnes qui habitent en zone inondable
qui suit un cyclone son impact et parce
que n'oublions pas que dans les modes il
peut y avoir des bouts de mayotte mais
nous parlons pour l'instant des gens qui
sont près des cours d'eau non inondable
déjà avec monsieur bel et on verra tout
allait dès 15 heures ces personnes avec
le ccn à la liste des gens on sait
puisque nous avons un plan communal de
sauvegarde
on sera déjà à quelle heure il faudra
activer les centres de refuge
on saura tout ça donc c'est pourquoi
nous suivons comme le lait sur le feu
l'arrivée du phénomène